[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
RYAN GREGG: My
name is Ryan Greg.
I'm a product manager on the
serverless team and on Knative.
MARK CHMARNY: I'm Mark Chmarny.
I'm one of the technical
program managers looking
after serverless at Google.
RYAN GREGG: Before
we get started,
I just wanted to take
a quick audience poll
and say, how many of
you use Kubernetes?
Cool.
How many--
MARK CHMARNY: You're
in the right session.
RYAN GREGG: What?
MARK CHMARNY: You're
in the right session.
RYAN GREGG: Yeah, that's right.
How many of you are
developers on Kubernetes?
You're writing apps that
run on the platform.
OK.
How many of you are
operators of Kubernetes?
You make sure that other
people's apps work.
Good.
MARK CHMARNY: I see a
lot of people who raised
their hands both occasions.
RYAN GREGG: That's right-- yeah.
And then, if you
didn't raise your hand,
what are you doing here?
[LAUGHTER]
Hm.
All right.
MARK CHMARNY: All right-- so
the session is called Kubernetes
or Run Serverless Everywhere.
We will get to the everywhere
portion in a minute.
But I want to break down the
serverless first part a little
and tease it into the
conversation after that.
To a large degree
today, if you talk
to people in the community,
serverless equals function.
You push some code
to your cloud.
And you have it
execute over there.
But is it really the case?
Is serverless only a function
as a service offering?
That's the question
I'm posing to you.
I think, to a large degree,
the properties of serverless
are pretty commonly
understood today.
And they break down into
two separate things.
First of all, is the
operational model--
how you run serverless--
maybe not develop,
but run the serverless.
So first of all, you shouldn't
have to worry about the servers
underneath.
It's right in a name.
I don't think we can
argue about that.
The other thing is
that it also comes
with a certain level
of trust, which
means, when you push your code
and it executes on a framework
that you do not
provide, that there
is a certain amount of security
that's integrated and managed
for you.
So you don't have to
worry about that either.
And you're paying
only for when you
use that service, when you're
actually doing something.
More importantly, you do not pay
when it's not doing something.
So when a code just sleeps
there and not doing anything--
you shouldn't pay for that.
So that's the operational model.
In the programming model--
the developer experience on
a serverless platform-- we
ideally have a service-based
developing model.
So you call APIs.
You don't run bunch
of scripts that you
have to move over and define
a bunch of environment
variables and all that.
And it's event-driven.
So you don't write
all kinds of code
to keep watching-- is
the file there yet?
Is the file there yet?
But you actually are
subscribing to an event.
Tell me when the file arrives.
And I will fire something.
These five are pretty
well understood.
And most people are agreed--
those properties are serverless.
What I would like to
add in here is one more.
And that's portability.
And I think, because
you're in a session titled,
"Runs Serverless
Everywhere," I assume,
portability is important to you.
So portability is
more than just being
able to take the code that
you have built in one platform
and able to take
it somewhere else
and run it on another platform.
It's about being able to expect
the same developer experience
on each one of those platforms.
So for example, the
Cloud Run service
that we announced this week--
Cloud Run that it's
managed and hosted
and Cloud Run that runs in GKE--
the same developer experience.
So it's not only
being able to move
this from one platform,
one operator, to another,
but being able to
depend and being
able to benefit
from the innovation
that that cloud service
provider offers for you.
And the other important
aspect of being portability
is that you don't
have to make a choice.
Day one, when you
start thinking-- you
have this great idea.
And you're going
to write some code.
You shouldn't have to,
at that point, say,
I'm going to write code that's
going to run on the platform x.
You should be able to use your
idiomatic developer experience.
Idiomatic is just a
fancy word for natural.
You don't have to
learn any special.
The way you develop in Go
or node.js applications
right now is the
very same way you
should be able to develop those
applications for serverless.
Now, that means
also that you should
be able to preserve
the investment.
There are technologies nowadays
coming and going every month.
And if we ask you to learn
yet another framework or yet
another set of APIs that
may be here tomorrow or not,
it doesn't preserve your skills.
So you have to continuously
learn new skills.
With serverless, we're
hoping that the experience is
so portable that not only the
technology and the tooling
is portable to
another environment,
but you actually are
able to take your skills
and be very productive
in another platform,
because the set of
experiences that
are exposed to you as a
developer are one and the same.
So I think, at this point, we
would agree that serverless
is bigger than just a function.
And I would pose, at this point,
that serverless is also bigger
than just compute.
If you look today at GCP--
at the portfolio of serverless
offerings on Google,
they span from everything from
data and analytics products,
machine learning--
and some call it AI.
Or message queuing
is serverless.
Or even the developer
experience--
so DevOps tooling is serverless.
And you might have seen
some of that yesterday
during the keynote in
Developer evening session.
So bigger than function,
bigger than compute--
and able to benefit and comprise
them with the same developer
experience.
All right-- I want
to ask Ryan now
to talk about serverless
on Kubernetes.
RYAN GREGG: Thanks, Mark.
So what about serverless
on Kubernetes?
That's an interesting idea.
First of all, I think
everybody in here--
because you're Kubernetes
operators or developers--
except for those of you who I
don't know why you're here--
understand that Kubernetes is
really the de facto platform
now for running containers
on the cloud, on prem,
anywhere that you want
to take those workloads.
In fact, there's
a giant ecosystem
with pretty much every cloud
provider, major and minor,
participating in running a
certified Kubernetes instance.
Kubernetes has really taken
off over the last four years
and become a de facto way of
doing container orchestration.
But what does it really look
like when you break it down?
Kubernetes, for
operators-- it's done a lot
to improve the
operator experience
for running containers.
It's taking care of the needs
of scheduling and lifecycle,
discovery, load
balancing, storage.
All the things that you had
to worry about and manage
and operate on your
own before, Kubernetes
has done a lot to make that
easier, more straightforward,
and simpler.
Did I just say
simple in Kubernetes?
Hm.
Anyway, there's a broad
number of features
that pull into this all these
great things that you can do.
And the really great thing
that Kubernetes has done
is it's created
this even platform
across all the different
environments where you can run.
So the learnings
and the knowledge
that you adopt as part
of using Kubernetes
apply whether you're running
Kubernetes on Google,
Kubernetes on prem, or
somewhere else in another cloud.
For the developer though--
developers really just
want to write code.
That's the core business
value that they provide.
But if you're building
on top of Kubernetes,
there's all these other
things that you have to do.
You have to containerize
your application.
You have to figure out how
to upload that application
into a container registry.
You have to actually deploy the
service, create the deployment,
and all the underlying objects
inside the Kubernetes API.
You then have to figure out how
to expose that to the internet
or to your service
mesh or whatever
the ingress gateway that
you're going to be using is.
You have to set up
logging and monitoring
and deal with all
of these aspects.
And then you have to figure
out how to properly scale
your workload.
You might have an
I/O bound workload
where you can put a lot
of concurrency into it.
Or you might have a
CPU-bound workload,
where you need to do
more horizontal scaling.
There's a lot there
and a lot more
of it than just writing code.
So earlier this week,
we introduced Cloud Run,
which is this concept
of bringing serverless
to containers and
trying to remove
a bunch of the details
of the infrastructure
and what underlies
what it takes to run
one of these containers
in the cloud.
And Cloud Run is available
as a fully-hosted service.
So you don't have the
Kubernetes aspect.
You don't have to
worry about any
of the details of what
cluster it's running in,
how it's horizontally scaled.
You just provide the
container into Google Cloud.
And we go run it for you, giving
you a URL that you can access,
giving you SSL--
all of the benefits of running
on a serverless platform.
Which is great.
But all of you aren't running
on a serverless platform.
You're running on Kubernetes.
So we didn't want
to leave you out.
So we also brought
Cloud Run on GKE,
which is the same
great Cloud Run
experience for the
developer, but running
on top of Kubernetes engine.
So it gives you the flexibility
to continue the Kubernetes
investment that
you've already made
but to get all of the
benefits of serverless
for your developers.
Things like automatic
scale, easy deployment,
network programming, and
automatic participation
in the service mesh
are all features
provided by Cloud Run on GKE.
It also integrates with all
of the Kubernetes features--
so using policy management--
is that what it's called?
I can never remember the
name of that feature, which
we announced this week.
The ability to
manage these things--
everything that you
do with Kubernetes
today applies to
Cloud Run on GKE,
because it's running on top of
your existing infrastructure.
It also means you
can take advantage
of the features of Kubernetes
on GKE, like custom nodes,
being able to bring in
custom machine sizes,
being able to access hardware
accelerators, like GPUs
and TPUs.
All of the advanced
compute features
that are available in the
Kubernetes platform that
aren't necessarily available
on a serverless platform
are yours on Cloud Run on GKE.
So we now have the ability
to offer serverless anywhere,
between a fully
serverless platform
that's managed
through Cloud Run,
where everything
is hidden from you
and you don't have to
worry about the details,
to Cloud Run on GKE, where
we manage the control plane
and provide the same
developer experience,
but it runs inside Kubernetes
Engine, and Knative,
which is the open
source platform that
makes all of this possible--
which allows you to run the same
API, the same control plane,
on any Kubernetes
installation anywhere.
So you can have the same
serverless experience
across the board,
from fully managed
all the way to do-it-yourself
with open source.
So let's step back and take
a look at this picture again.
With Cloud Run on top of
GKE, now developers really
can just focus on
writing their code.
They can have that serverless
developer experience
and still run it on top
of all of your Kubernetes
infrastructure.
And they don't need
to worry about all
of those other concerns, so
they can be more productive
and get more done.
Let's go a little
bit deeper though--
because this is a
200-level talk--
and talk about-- what are the
actual benefits that you get
out of using Cloud Run on GKE?
So when I deploy my container
on Cloud Run on GKE,
using the serverless
infrastructure on Kubernetes
Engine, I get my container
automatically scaled,
including scaling to 0.
So we look at the
HTTP traffic that
is coming into this service.
And if there isn't any
after a period of time,
the container will time-out.
We'll spin down the pod.
And it's taking up no
resources inside your cluster.
When a request
comes in, it lands
on an activator component,
which understands
which service definitions
we need to go spin up.
We'll create a pod
or multiple pods,
depending on how much
traffic is coming in,
and start routing the
connections directly
to those instances.
And we'll scale up
from 1, obviously,
to as many as it takes to
serve the load that you have.
And there are some
parameters that you
can use to fine-tune
how that scaling works.
We also offer managed
configurations and revisions.
So we keep track
of every revision
of a service that is deployed
through Cloud Run on GKE.
And you can easily
move between them.
You can roll back
to an older version.
Say, you deploy something
new and there's an error.
You can quickly revert back.
We also ensure that,
while we're moving over
to the new revision,
there's no downtime.
Requests that are
coming in seamlessly
get migrated from one instance
in one version to the next one,
so your service can
remain live in production,
as you deploy a new version.
We also integrate with
the Istio service mesh,
because we're running
on Kubernetes.
So every service that's deployed
through Cloud Run on GKE
is a member of the service mesh.
And you can choose to expose
that service either externally,
outside the cluster, or
only on the service mesh,
if you want to do
an internal service.
And Mark's going to do a
really cool demo about that
in a little bit.
And then another great
benefit of Cloud Run on GKE
is that it enables the custom
domain story and certificate
management story on
top of the cluster
for serverless services.
So we automatically generate
URLs for those services.
That can be on a
custom domain name,
so that you don't have to
worry about all of the plumbing
to make that happen.
And then, of course, Cloud Run
on GKE is built on top of GKE.
So it can connect into a
bunch of great GCP services,
like Cloud Build
and Stackdriver,
for doing logging
and monitoring.
But it's also a
pluggable infrastructure.
So if you want to extend it
with a partner integration,
like Datadog, you can
do that, if that's
what your business depends on.
Or you can use GitLab
as the CI/CD system.
And we'll show you
a little bit more
about how that works
here in a little bit.
So let me give you a demo of
what this actually looks like--
just to get a little bit
more real than me talking.
So if we could
switch to demo 1--
aha.
Here I am in Cloud Console.
This probably looks very
familiar to everybody here.
And I'm going to go
into Kubernetes Engine,
just to show you what it
looks like to stand this up.
So I will create a cluster
and wait for my UI to load.
And I'm going to
go ahead and create
a highly-available
cluster, because that's
what you should be using if
you have production workloads.
And I'm going to scroll
down to the bottom.
And I'm going to turn
on Stackdriver logging
and monitoring.
I'm going to turn on Istio.
And I'm going to turn
on Cloud Run on GKE.
And I'm not actually
going to click Create,
because it takes a little
bit too long for a demo.
But that's how easy it is to
stand up a cluster that Cloud
Run on GKE can run on.
Today, you can only do that
when you create a cluster.
But very soon, we'll
give you the option
of doing that on an
existing cluster as well.
And once I have it
running, I can move over
to the Cloud Run UI now.
And this is really the
developer experience
for deploying applications
into this environment.
If you think of the
Kubernetes Engine control
pane as being the operator
experience in Kubernetes,
Cloud Run gives you the
developer experience
on top of Cloud Run on GKE.
And I can just click
to create a service.
I can browse to find a
container image, in this case.
I'll pick this one.
It seems like the
right shaw to me.
And I will choose to put this
into my Kubernetes Engine
cluster, instead of into
the managed namespace.
And I'll just use
Default. I'll say
that I want it to be
exposed externally,
so that I can actually show you
what service I have deployed.
And I'll click Create.
And what this is doing right
now is using the Knative API
to go out and define a Knative
service on this cluster.
And under the covers,
Knative is doing
all of the work necessary
to create the activator,
manage the routing, program
Istio to enable the URL that I
have here to work, and
making the whole system up
and running.
And now, you can see--
my revision is deployed
and ready for me to activate.
Click on that.
And you can see,
here's my PDF service.
If you came to the developer
keynote last night,
you'll be like, hey,
I saw this before.
But this is just a
microservice that
allows you to convert a
Word document into a PDF--
a very simple.
You can see that it's
running on Cloud Run on GKE.
I can actually go back and
deploy the same service
onto the hosted Cloud
Run experience--
the managed Cloud Run.
And you'll see, it's
exactly the same experience
as I had before.
But this time, I'm going to pick
one of these Cloud Run regions.
And well-- make sure
I check this box.
This is deploying it into
the fully managed serverless
experience, where there
is no GKE cluster.
There's nothing
actually backing this.
And you see-- the developer
experience is the same.
So all that is really cool.
But what about Knative?
What about being able to run
the service in other places
as well?
So I'm going to show the
last step of this demo, which
is actually using the
Knative API, the underlying
open source, on an IBM cloud
cluster, as just an example.
It could have been any
Kubernetes cluster anywhere.
But I happen to have one
of those easily available.
So I'm going to use Gcloud
Run to get my service yaml--
PDF service.
And you'll see, here's
the Knative API yaml
for my service.
If I scroll up,
you'll see, there's
a bunch of metadata, of course.
But the spec is pretty simple.
It's just saying to run the
latest version of this revision
and for this particular image.
This is the Knative
API, very simply.
And I've actually put
this into service.yaml,
just to show that I'm not lying.
And I will do kubectl.apply
into my other cluster,
the service.yaml.
And this is going
to do the same thing
that the UI was doing before--
create this Knative service
on this Kubernetes cluster.
And I can do, Get K Service.
And you'll see, that service
is now up and running.
I have a URL that I can access,
from this other service.
And thanks to the
power of Knative,
I have the same thing running.
So we have the same
portability of the experience
that normal Kubernetes
would give you.
But I didn't have to worry
about any of the details of how
to program Kubernetes,
how to make it auto scale,
how to do all of those
developer complexity things
that I didn't want to do before.
Knative, Cloud Run,
and Cloud Run on GKE
have taken care of that.
So as a developer, I can
just focus on writing my code
and not be concerned with all
of the other details of what
I have to worry about.
If we could switch back
to the slides, please--
so to give you a little bit
more example of how all of this
works in action--
you need to give
your thing to him--
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN GREGG: I'd like to
bring up Daniel Gruesso,
from GitLab, to show you
how GitLab has integrated
with Cloud Run on
GKE and Knative
to provide a portable
experience for [INAUDIBLE]..
DANIEL GRUESSO:
Hello-- hello-- hello.
Hi.
So thank you, Ryan.
So at GitLab, we
couldn't agree more.
Kubernetes is the
de facto platform
for running containers.
And we've worked
to integrate all
of those workflows
in our product.
So serverless is no different.
We believe Knative
is an important part
of enabling the
development experience
and basically really
allowing developers
to focus on writing code and
applications and adding value
and not having to
focus on maintaining
infrastructure and configuring
it and all of those things.
So as you know, GitLab
provides a unified experience
for operators and
developers, where
you can manage both your
code and your infrastructure
from a single app.
So there's a lot
of power in that.
So let's see what
that's all about.
Can we switch to demo 2?
All right-- so here I
have my GitLab project.
Let's head over to
operations and Kubernetes.
So I see here that the operator
has set up a Kubernetes cluster
on my project.
And Cloud Run on GKE
has been enabled here.
I see that the domain that
I requested for my app
has been configured-- in
this case, GitLabCloud.run.
So here's where the benefits of
GitLab start to become visible.
Here, I see that,
with a single click,
an operator can configure that
domain to the Istio ingress
end-point.
And behind the scenes,
what's that's doing is
it's adding the
domain to config map
to resolve all the requests to
the service, using this domain.
So I didn't have to
expose any configuration
on Kubernetes-- anything.
It's a single click op.
So that's really great.
Let's move onto
the project here.
And let's take a look.
And let's take a look at
how easy it is to deploy
a service on Cloud Run on GKE.
So there are two types of
services that I could deploy.
I could deploy a
function as a service.
Or I could deploy a
full serverless app.
And Knative will scale it up
and down, based on the requests.
So for this demo, I will go
ahead and deploy a function.
So I only need two templates.
The first one is
the GitLabCI.yaml.
And basically, this contains a
reference to the Cloud Run CLI
that we're using.
That will take care of building
and deploying your Cloud Run
service.
And then the second template
is the serverless.yaml.
So I only need this one if I'm
going to deal with functions.
And here, basically, it provides
information about my functions,
such as the name, description,
the runtime that I'm using.
In this case, it's going to be
a TriggerMesh node.js runtime.
And that's it.
So that's really all
I need to get started.
So the very next thing
that I'm going to do
is I'm going to
add the files that
are specific to my function.
So here, I'm just going
to add three files.
The first file is echo.js.
This is a simple function that
will echo back whatever input
I give to it.
And the other two
files are JSON files
that hold the metadata
for my service.
So that's it.
Let's go ahead and add
those to the project.
Let's give this a commit message
here at echo function files--
and push.
All right-- so let's make sure
that all those files made it
back to my repo properly.
Great-- I see that the Echo
directory made it here.
And it contains all of the
files that I just pushed.
So this, in turn, will
create a CI pipeline
that will actually take care
of building and deploying
the Knative service.
So it takes about a
minute to complete.
So let me show you what it
looks like when it's done.
Here, I can see
the whole process
in a single stage of
building and deploying
the Cloud Run on GKE service.
So when this happens,
this will populate
an entry in my serverless page.
So that's under
Operations and Serverless.
And the entry on
this page is going
to be a reference to
the Knative service.
So here, as soon
as it loads, we'll
see a couple of things that
are specific to the service.
All right-- so I see here,
the service name, the service
description, and
the end point where
the service is being served.
And that's it.
So that means that my
service is now out there.
And I should be able to
send the requests to it.
And hopefully, it will work.
And it will echo back
whatever input I give to it.
So for this first test,
let's give it this input,
Hello from Google Next 2019.
Here, I'm just
going to use curl.
So you see the content
type, the request type,
and the end point.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So here, the service
is scaling from 0.
So it's going to spin up
whatever resources it needs.
And I see that it
echoed back this data.
So let's try it a
second time here.
This time, I'll pass it
GitLab serverless functions
on Cloud Run for GKE.
So you see that
that second time,
it was a lot faster, because
the resources have already
been spun up.
And then basically, as you
give it load, it will scale up.
And when there's no load, it
will scale back down to 0.
So here, if we click on my
service, I'll see more detail.
I see-- because this is
running on Cloud Run for GKE--
there's a Kubernetes cluster.
And I will see the
scale for my functions.
So in this case, I see that
it's using only one pod.
As you give it more
traffic, you'll
see more pods spun up here.
And very soon, we'll add
the number of invocations
that you have for
your functions.
So as you can see, it was very
simple to deploy a service
from 0.
And while it's
still early, you can
see that there's a
lot of power in that.
And like Ryan
said, we don't have
to concern ourselves with
being experts in Kubernetes.
And this is being added
to GitLab CE, which
is open source.
So you can feel free to
contribute any use cases
that you may need on top of it.
And that's all I have.
Back to you, Mark.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK CHMARNY: I'm going
to switch back to slides.
Daniel walked us through
some of the benefits
and the overview of
the demo and gave us
a good idea of how we can
partner, using the Knative
APIs that are very open, with
a broader number of partners
in the community that enable--
whether it's CI/CD,
whether it's logging,
whether all the
extra capabilities
that you might
potentially depend on
when you were
developing on premise
and how you want to use them in
a more distributed environment,
whether it's in a cloud or
continue developing on premise,
but using some of the
technologies that Cloud Run or,
specifically, Knative enable.
So what I'm going to do now--
I'm going to go in and maybe
highlight another use case that
captures some of the
more real-life scenarios,
as when you're developing a more
microservice-based solution.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to start with a very
simplistic use case, which
is a single service deployed
on Cloud Run that exposes
a REST interface to the outside
world that can be invoked
with an image that then it's
turning around and calling
a Google Cloud Vision API to
get an identification of a logo
that might be included
in that image.
What we're going to do then--
we're going to say, OK.
That's great.
Except now, everybody
in the world
is able to run my credits
against Vision API, which
is something I probably don't
want to enable too much.
So we're going to front this
with yet another microservice,
which is going to
provide authentication,
using Google OAuth service,
and expose a simple UI, also,
so that users can interact
with that API much easier.
That's great-- except, if you're
paying attention right now,
you're quickly realizing
that both of those services
are exposed to
the outside world.
So you probably
all say, ha ha ha.
I can just go around there.
And I can continue calling
my original service.
And everything is
going to be great.
So let's see how
services on Cloud Run
can help you to deal with
this kind of situation.
Can we switch it to demo 1?
All right-- so I have
a simple image here.
You and I know what it is.
I've seen a lot of
hands raised initially,
when we kicked off the
session, talking about people
who know what Kubernetes is.
So you probably know what it is.
But when a machine asks
and looks at that image,
it might know what it is.
So the Vision API provides
one of its sub-services
that allow you to
identify logos.
So actually, before we
even go there, let's
first of all deploy this image.
I wouldn't want to run a REST
service against something that
doesn't exist.
So first of all,
we're going to run--
it looks a little complex,
because we're including some
of the additional services.
So Ryan has deployed
service, using UI.
I'm going to show you how
to do this using Gcloud--
exactly the same experience,
the same variables, but just
different tool.
So obviously,
Gcloud is the tool.
We're going to use Run,
which is the service we
are announcing here.
We're going to deploy.
Here's my creative
service that, apparently,
always has to start with K now.
And we're going to add a
couple additional variables.
We're going to deploy an image.
You've seen, during
the demos-- as often,
for ease of demonstration--
deploy an image
with Latest, which
is great for demonstration.
You probably would not want
to do that in real-life.
You want a specific hash
shot of the image that
represents a state of
that image, as it was,
that will allow you to
benefit from the auto scaling,
without worrying that, when
you deploy the service today
and an image and
the solution has
to scale to additional
nodes tomorrow,
that you're pulling a
different version of the image.
So a consistent, same
version of the image
is going to be on
every single service.
And we're also
providing a couple
additional environment variables
in here, like a release mode.
So let's do this.
Now, the thing I like to point
out here during the demos is--
this is pretty fast.
When you think about--
docker images can
get pretty large--
how fast you do this and
how quickly you can deploy
it is pretty impressive.
So what Cloud Run gave us
here is a specific version--
so the name of the service plus
some unique characters there.
It also gave us a URL.
I have this entire cluster
configured with a custom domain
and SSL certificates, so we can
actually resemble real-- more--
world scenario.
So let's go back to our kernel.
And let's run it.
So the simple thing--
we're going to post a JSON
object, which is very simple.
It has only an ID and a URL.
And then we're going to
pipe it through jQuery,
so we can have a little
more color over response.
So we see here, very quickly,
the service was running.
It returned an identification.
It identified it as Kubernetes.
I'm actually underselling
the Vision API.
Vision API returns
a broad number
of set of features
of that image,
including attributes,
colors, and all other things.
I'm just extracting one
thing for ease of demo.
But Cloud Vision API is
pretty impressive service.
OK, so what we're
going to do now is--
REST interface is great.
But where are we?
Let's deploy the UI
application, so we can actually
take a look at it.
Again-- much bigger command--
yes, there's more environment
variables in here.
But bottom line is we're going
to run the exact same thing.
And when that is done--
great-- we can actually switch
to the browser and start
using--
can you guys see it?
Yeah-- so clearly,
an application
created for
demonstration purposes.
There's not much there.
But one thing that we
can do is we can easily
log in here into a service.
I'm going to my
personal one, so I'm not
exposing any Google stuff here.
And we have a nice UI.
Oh, I have to go shopping.
I think it's the same
t-shirt I was wearing
when I was taking the picture.
All right-- so back to
our Kubernetes image--
we can run this
through the same UI.
But like we said,
there is this problem
that I can continue coming back
to my curl and just running it.
So clearly not
working as intended.
I'm going to come back
to this UI in here.
We have this new version.
Let's refresh this, because we
just deployed a new version.
So now, you see, three minutes
ago, I deployed a new one.
There's a number of features
here logging details.
You see the
environment variables.
You can actually
see the yaml file
that Ryan has deployed
across IBM Cloud and ours.
You can assume the same thing
with environment variables.
The one thing I want
to highlight here--
in addition to these
other capabilities,
you can actually come in here
and very easily change this
to an internal service.
So let's wait for
this to finish.
Let's come over here
and, first of all,
clear this and maybe
do a little verbose.
All right-- so curl
is a lot more verbose.
But the important
thing is over here.
First of all, the
service was 404.
So it's not like we put some
kind of token or security
on it.
We literally removed
the route to it.
It's not accessible
from outside world.
The other thing you
should notice here--
automatically, we recognize that
this traffic supports HTTP/2.
So we've upgraded the
service to HTTP/2.
So let's now see if our
UI continues working.
Because if we just shut
down the back-end service,
that's probably not
what we wanted, right?
Now, I don't think we used
YouTube before-- yeah?
There it is.
So our service is able to
use the back-end service
internally, inside
of the cluster,
by discovering its internal
URL and consuming that,
versus using the external.
That's a great
capability that allows
you to start mix and
match different services.
And you continue benefiting
from the Istio mesh that's
running underneath to
give you telemetry,
access posts, your request
paths, and all that.
In fact, Istio request
path access pattern
is actually used in here to
deliver that very capability.
All right-- so let's
switch to slides.
So what we've done
here-- just to recap--
we've deployed a
number of services.
Actually, going a little
further, what I've done
is deployed yet another service
that's providing a metering.
So we actually keep a state
of each user's requests.
And we persist them
into Firestore API,
so even if you were
to go to the UI
and start using it
thousands of times,
I will shut you down after
hundreds of queries per day.
So we have a number
of back-end services
that are accessible
only internally.
They're accessible to the
front UI as a backing service.
But the front UI
is the only service
that's exposed externally.
It allows users and forces them
to authenticate-- a little more
real-world scenario
of how you would
develop these applications.
And the beauty of this
is that you can continue
to keep building on that.
You can continue adding,
using Cloud Run on GKE.
You can continue
building the services.
And behind the scene, if the
UI is not exposing something,
you can use kubectl
to manage this,
as if this was normal Kubernetes
service that was deployed by--
so, Ryan.
Tell us again about-- what are
the different options we have
and where we can
run these services,
using Knative back services?
RYAN GREGG: [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you, Mark.
That was, I think, a cool demo.
Did everybody else think
that was a cool demo?
[APPLAUSE]
MARK CHMARNY:
[INAUDIBLE] to beg for--
RYAN GREGG: No, I'll
beg for applause.
That's fine.
That's a product manager job.
So serverless where you want
it with Knative and Cloud Run--
I want to emphasize the
portability aspect here.
Because really, what
we're trying to do
is make it so that you can
have the developer experience
of serverless in any
environment where you
want to enable that experience.
We know that not everybody
fits into the mold of what
a fully-hosted serverless
option can offer
and that there are lots of
reasons why customers want
to stay on GKE, on Kubernetes,
and run on Kubernetes, really,
anywhere.
But the developer
experience shouldn't have
to change as a result of that.
You should be able to get
the same experience for how
you write code--
being idiomatic, as Mark
said-- my favorite word--
across all the
different ecosystems,
so that not just the
workload can be portable--
like I showed, being able
to deploy the same thing
in multiple places--
but that the skills can
transfer-- that the developer
experience can be portable,
so that what I learned today
using Cloud Run on GKE
can, on my next project,
be applied to Cloud Run
and, on the next project,
be applied to an
on-premises cluster.
And so we've announced
these products--
Cloud Run, Cloud Run on GKE,
which are in beta today.
I really encourage everybody to
take them out and try these out
today and give them a try.
And look at Knative as well, if
you have a Kubernetes cluster,
where you're interested in
running serverless workloads.
Oh, I talked about this already.
So there's a bunch of
related sections, of course.
This is afternoon on Thursday,
so almost all of these
have already happened.
They're all going
to be on YouTube
in a matter of a few days.
So please, go back
and watch them
if you're interested more in
Knative or in the overall Cloud
Run vision.
I do want to plug,
though, the SVR305 that's
happening this afternoon,
which is a deep dive on Knative
eventing.
So everything that
we talked about today
is on the serving path and
being able to auto-scale
your workloads.
But if you're familiar with
how we define serverless--
in one of the slides
that Mark talked about,
there is that
event-driven piece,
which we didn't talk
about a whole lot
today, because it's still
coming through Knative eventing.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
and Mark are going
to be presenting both the vision
of where eventing is going
as well as some really
cool demos showing
how eventing can be used today.
So definitely check that out.
MARK CHMARNY: And maybe
one thing to add in here
is that, clearly,
this is beta product.
Cloud Run is still
in beta right now.
And Knative itself
is 0.5 release.
A lot of the use
cases that you're
trying to address,
specifically on premise,
are something that
we would be very
interested to understand
better and see
how Knative solves for those.
So if you are at all dealing
with Kubernetes and serverless
seems like something
that Knative and Cloud
Run can help you with,
please, use some of those URLs
in here, including-- there
are some feedbacks on Twitter.
As well as Knative.dev
has some additional links
you can use to give us some
ideas of what's missing
or what else can
we add to Cloud Run
itself to make this more
appropriate for some of the use
cases you're trying
to solve with.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]